.
- On a recensé 1337 nouveaux cas
de COVID hier en C
nos standards, mais qui a suffi
à convaincre les responsablresps
chinois de confiner 17 millions
d'habitants de Schenzen et
d'imposees villes.
- Depuis le début de
la pandémie, la Chine applique
avec succès sa politique
de tolérance zéro à la COVID.
est immense.
- Mais pendant qu'on serre
la vis en Chine, en Europe
Aujourd'hui, en France,
presque toutes les barrières
ont sautées.
Et on sent les choses. Je ne
sentais plus, depuis un certain
temps.et c'est plus agréable
de travailler sans masque.
- Mais il y a un revers
au relâchement des mesures
sanitairsignifsignifsignifsignis
en février, on observe
maintenant une hausse
dans une demi-douzaine de pays,
d'une augmentation des
hospitalisations. La montée
en force du sous-variant BA.2
pourrait aussi exp
ce phénomène.
BENOIT BARBEAU, prof virologie
- C'est certainement lui
qui a pris d'assaut les pays
européens. On sait qu'il est
au moins 30 % plus transmissible
Omicron.
- Et puis il y a l......
On le sait, même les meilleurs
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE, immunologue
Institut cardio de Montréal
- Et la troisième raison,
de la protection vacinale,
c'est quasiment une consta
qu'on voit avec ces vaccins-
- En théorie, disent
ialistes, cette remontée
en Europe pourrait se
transposer en Amérique, commes
précédentes, au Québec,
lleurs.
- Je crois qu'on devrait plutôt
attendre de voir cvoir un peu
plt8
,
avant d'annoncer clairement
si oui on retire le masque.
des nouveaux cas de COVID
au Québec sont liés
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon